und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers guten
Abend in allen das ist so als hätte man
eine halbgut gesicherte Unfallstelle auf
dem Randstreifen einer Autobahn so
beschreibt ein Meeresschützer die
bisherige Position des brennenden Auto
Frachters in der Nordsee deshalb jetzt
also ein aufwendiges und durchaus
riskantes abschleppmanöver an einen
neuen Ankerplatz entlang der
niederländischen Wattenmeerinseln damit
ist der Brand nicht gelöscht und die
Umweltgefahr nicht gebannt aber
zumindest etwas aufatmen möglich die
großen Fragen bleiben sie betreffen die
Sicherheit von solchen autotransporten
auf hoher See gerade in Zeiten in denen
immer mehr Elektroautos mit Batterien
unterwegs sind Gunnar Krüger berichtet
es ist nur eine zwischen Etappe aber
immerhin die Free mental Highway liegt
der Mittag auf ihrem vorläufigen
Ankerplatz seit Sonntag zogen sie
Schlepper von terzelling ein Ameland
vorbei bis 16 km vor hoch
abends begann die Aktion der Wind stand
günstig der rauchnabel ab 66 km teils
bei Windstärke 5 die Höhle hat keine
Risse der Rumpf ist heil und doch bleibt
der Frachter ein Risiko
das Schiff ist stabil das ist für uns
das Wichtigste es kommt langsamer voran
als erwartet aber Sicherheit geht vor
Tempo das Wetter ist eben schlecht es
gibt viel Wind und wir wollen sicher
Vorgehen darum braucht es Zeit
nun hat die Insel ganz neue Aussichten
die Bürgermeisterin kann und muss damit
leben
überall nur nicht bei uns so läuft das
nicht die Wasserbehörde sagt das ist der
sicherste Ankerplatz und damit finden
wir uns ab es ist wichtig dass wir als
Wattenmeerinseln solidarisch sind und
den besten Ort akzeptieren
darauf spricht Vertrauen auf das Können
einer Seefahrer Nation er steckt auch
Zugereiste Insulaner an wie den
deutschen Künstler lotharbracht
wir sind irgendwie ein Teil von dem
ganzen Dingen und jetzt die Panik zu
kriegen weil das Shifter liegt das ist
gefährlich aber Angst ist da der
schlechteste Beratung als Reaktion auf
den Frachter hat er ein Sandbild gemalt
und es selbst gedreht autofrei will ist
jemand nicht hoch sein in jeder Hinsicht
Autos die vom Fracht der fallen das
bleibe hoffentlich nur eine
Schreckensvision
so wir gehen live nach Screen monok hoch
ich hoffe ich habe das halbwegs richtig
gesagt ultra guten Abend eine Etappe
wäre also geschafft wie konkret soll es
denn jetzt weitergehen
[Applaus]
also Etappen Sieg ist glaube ich das
Gefühl was hier auf der Insel vor
herrscht man hat das Gefühl man ist
einigermaßen davon gekommen weil dieser
Frachter stabil ist aber man hat weiter
Angst viele Leute sagen es ist eine
tickende Zeitbombe die vor der Insel
eben ist man konnte den ganzen Tag ihn
mit den Augen sehen so dicht ist an der
Insel dran jetzt ist ein bisschen dunkel
und es regnet stark aber das hat den
Leuten viel Angst gemacht was macht man
jetzt konkret man hat quasi zwei
Schleppboote neben dem neben dem
Frachter um ihn zu stabilisieren und
dann versucht man wie das technisch
heißt dass das Feuer ausbrennt das ist
irgendwann aufhört weil das ist das
entscheidend jetzt dass man das Feuer in
den Griff kriegt das kann auch sein dass
man noch mal löschen muss was nicht ganz
unproblematisch ist weil das Löschwasser
das läuft in den Frachter rein und kann
dann gefährlich zu gefährlichen
Schieflagen führen und das wenn man
vermeiden dass alle wichtigste jetzt ist
das sagen alle Experten ist dass die
Außenhaut quasi der Kapitel des
Frachters weiter einigermaßen kühl
bleibt weil wenn der aber jetzt gibt es
Ritze Risse und dann entsteht die
Katastrophe öl tritt aus und das wird
gar keiner dass wenn man auf alle Fälle
vermeiden aber wie gesagt das kann man
immer noch nicht ausschließen es gibt
Ulf viele solcher Autotransporte aktuell
über die Weltmeere vielleicht noch mal
von dem aktuellen Fall ein bisschen
losgelöst welche Ideen welche
Forderungen gibt es denn jetzt für
grundsätzliches neu denken bei solchen
autotransporten
also da haben wir auch mit den Leuten
hier auf der Insel gesprochen die ja
schon lange darüber nachdenken es hat ja
schon mal eine Katastrophe gegeben 2019
hier für die Insel da hat ein Container
Frachtschiff 400 Container verloren die
sind dann alle an die Insel gespielt
worden hat große Verschmutzung
verursacht die radikalen sagen hier wir
müssen einfach die Schifffahrtsrouten
die hier so eng an dem Watten mehr
vorbei gehen einfach verbieten oder
nicht mehr zulassen aber das ist
wahrscheinlich sehr sehr illusorisch
weil diese Schifffahrtsrouten sind die
lebenswerten der Weltwirtschaft das
wirklich stattfinden manche und das sind
doch dann vielleicht die entscheidenden
Antworten denken da ein wenig kleiner
man sagt man muss diese Frachtern noch
besser ausrüsten die Löschsysteme
sprühsysteme müssen deutlicher werden
und dann steht auf der Tagesordnung noch
die Gefahr der Elektroautos noch ist
nicht klar ob sie die Ursache sind aber
darüber wird auch diskutiert wie gesagt
man steht da am Anfang aber man will
darüber diskutieren aus dem Regen an der
niederländischen Küste live herzlichen
Dank und das Wetter zieht sich so ein
bisschen durch unsere Sendung heute auch
unseren nächsten Beitrag wenn zwei
Ministerpräsidenten zusammen wandern
gehen dann darf man politisches Kalkül
vermuten und viel PR die Schönheit der
nordhessischen Landschaft rund um
Willingen allein wird es jedenfalls
nicht gewesen sein dem einen MP werden
Ambitionen auf eine Kanzlerkandidatur
zugeschrieben der andere hat eine
Landtagswahl vor der Brust Hendrik wüst
NRW und Boris rein Hessen eint neben
einer 270 km langen gemeinsamen
Landesgrenze auch ein gemeinsamer
Parteichef der gerade einiges an
Gegenwind aushalten muss auch aus den
eigenen Reihen
und so werden sie heute auch in der
Bundespolitik genau gucken was die CDU
wann das Leute in der Provinz da
veranstalten Peter Wagner
hallo guten Tag Boris rein und Hendrik
wüst beide CDU beide um die 50 beide
Ministerpräsidenten beide regieren mit
Schwarz-Grün beide gehen wandern in
beginnenden hessischen Wahlkampf sind
wanderbilder willkommen auch wenn es
stürmt und regnet und die Skywalk Brücke
in Willingen ganz schön schwankt ich
glaube wenn die
Höhenmeter
Herausforderung mit dabei auf dem
Wanderweg von Hessen nach
Nordrhein-Westfalen 50 Journalisten und
zwei Themen die AFD und all das was
CDU-Chef Friedrich Merz dazu der letzten
Woche gesagt hat oder gemeint hat was er
klarstellen musste und ob er die Partei
auch richtig führt ich finde das wenn
sie auf für den Bundesvorsitzenden
anspielen der Bundesvorsitzende klar
führt ich finde auch dass er in seiner
Frage der Neubesetzung des
Generalsekretärs eine Führung
vorgenommen
Rückendeckung aus Hessen für Friedrich
Merz oder ist es Schadensbegrenzung der
Wanderweg führt zufall oder nicht in den
Hochsauerlandkreis und das ist der
Wahlkreis des CDU-Vorsitzenden wir sind
aber auch jetzt direkt gleich im
Wahlkreis von Friedrich Merz kommt der
denn so schön haben sie sich angemeldet
sollte ein Zusammentreffen von zwei
Ministerpräsidenten die
grenzüberschreitende Themen besprechen
die beide Landesregierungen betreffen
und dann nehmen wir gerne zusammen
arbeiten und mit Friedrich sind für ein
anderer Stelle in einem guten Austausch
guter Austausch anderswo sagt man dazu
möglicherweise wir haben mal Tacheles
geredet und dann gibt es noch eine
Pressekonferenz durch Nest in der
dampfigen Wanderhütte die Optik der
Kamera beschlägt das Bild unscharf
scharf und deutlich die Abgrenzung zur
AFD wir haben in aller Klarheit gesagt
es ist eine ganz klare brennmauer zu AFD
gibt die
mit dem AFD passt nicht zu Christlich
Demokratischen werten das hat sie erst
wieder am Wochenende jetzt auf ihrem
Bundesparteitag mit teilweise wirklich
widerwärtigen Aussagen
unter Beweis gestellt und deswegen gibt
es nicht nur eine Brandmauer zu AFD
sondern es gibt auch einen tiefen Graben
der nicht überwindbar ist dass die AFD
gerade da steht wo sie steht in Umfragen
das liegt an der Bundesregierung und
daran dass man ein halbes Jahr lang die
Menschen verunsichert hat mit dieser
heizungsgesetz Debatte war da nicht noch
ein Thema offen
Kanzlerfrage sie haben schon gesagt sie
sie würden bereitstellen wie wie geht's
da weiter in den nächsten Wochen
ein politischer Wandertag an dem zwei
CDU Ministerpräsidenten vieles geben um
die Bundespartei zu stabilisieren und
das ausgerechnet im Wahlkreis von
Friedrich Merz
wenn man die Situation in Israel
schlicht als Frage von Sieg oder
Niederlage betrachtet dann hat die
Regierung von Ministerpräsident Benjamin
Netanjahu einen Sieg geholt ein
Kernelement seiner umstrittenen
Justizreform ist durchs Parlament und in
Kraft der Preis dafür ist schon jetzt
gewaltig es geht um viel mehr als Sieg
oder Niederlage es geht um mittlerweile
um Israel wie wir es kennen wie es die
Israelis kennen der Riss geht mitten
durchs Land durch Familien und Büros
durch die Armee seit 30 Wochen gibt es
Massenproteste auf den Straßen des
Landes und die sollen nicht aufhören im
Gegenteil immer von dabei eine
renommierte Physikerin und Mutter von
fünf Kindern Stefanie gagorsch stellt
sie vor
die Krise Israels ihres Landes hat sie
ins Rampen nicht gespült schick mal
Bresler ist das weibliche Gesicht des
Widerstandes gegen netanjas
rechtsrellinghose Koalition ihre Worte
eine Demonstranten Schaf und klar
durch die Entscheidung die Gerichte zu
schwächen haben wir alle verstanden ohne
Ausnahme dass diese Regierung die von
einer radikalen Gruppe geleitet wird
nicht aufhören wird bis in Israel eine
Diktatur errichtet hat sie wollen alles
zerstören was sie ihnen im Weg steht um
dieses Ziel zu erreichen
am Samstagabend sind es die ersten
großen Proteste nachdem nettern Jahres
Regierung ein Teil der umstrittenen
Justizreform geschlossen hat
wiederkommen Massen die 30 Woche in
Folge dafür haben sie schickma einen
Kuchen gebacken
sie ist ein halt eine Ikone für die
Demonstranten
die Leute folgen ihr weil sie an das
glauben was sie sagt sie hat es
geschafft die unterschiedlichsten
Menschen im Protest zu vereinen und zu
verbinden
wissen Sie in unserem Land gibt es einen
großen Graben zwischen dem was Leute
sagen und dem was sie tun schick mal tut
was sie sagt seit 30 Wochen schon
[Musik]
unermüdlich ist sie dabei auch wenn sie
manchmal lieber zu Hause wäre bei ihren
fünf Kindern dabei habe sie nie den Ruhm
gesucht wolle keine politische Karriere
sagt sie sieht es mehr als ihre Pflicht
an diesen historischen Kampf zu führen
einer meiner Großväter kam aus
Deutschland hierher alle anderen sind in
Israel geboren alle haben für dieses
Land gekämpft und haben Freunde verloren
auch ich und nun dies etwa 70% der
Israelis unterstützen uns im gegen das
was die Regierung tut es sind die
kreativsten Köpfe darunter und wir
werden nicht aufgeben Wir haben noch
lange nicht alle unsere Mittel des
zivilen Ungehorsams ausgeschöpft
immer weiter führt sie den Protest auf
der Straße in ihrem schwarzen T-Shirt
wurde dafür sogar kurzzeitig verhaftet
schick mal Bresler sie ist auch eine
Astrophysikerin arbeitet am berühmten
Weiz mein Institut bei Tel Aviv gilt als
ausgleichend und kreativ vor ein paar
Jahren schrieb sie eine Symphonie über
Partikel und Teilchen
die Freiheit des Geistes ihr
Lebenselixier
Rückschläge ein Ansporn
wir haben eine Etappe im Kampf verloren
ja ein Teil der Justizreform ist
beschlossen aber das letzte Wort ist
noch nicht gesprochen die sind
historische Momente wir können nicht
zurückweichen wir können nur vorwärts
gehen damit wir nicht in dunkle Zeiten
Segeln stattdessen müssen wir einen Weg
finden unsere Demokratie zu stärken
[Musik]
schick mal Bresler sie will alles dafür
tun dass die Demokratie in Israel am
Ende gewinnt
zurück nach Deutschland im gerade
laufenden Bayern Wahlkampf kann die CSU
eines ganz schlecht gebrauchen dass
daran erinnert wird wie teuer die Fehler
des ehemaligen
csu-verkehrsministers und aktuell
Bundestagsabgeordneten andreas Scheuer
beim Maut Desaster sind für die
Steuerzahler aber exakt das dass nämlich
daran erinnert wird passiert heute
wieder Hanna
denn Bundesverkehrsminister Wissing
lässt nun prüfen ob der Bund im
Zusammenhang mit der gescheiterten
pkw-maut-schadensersatz von seinem
Vorgänger andreas Scheuer fordern kann
ein Gutachten soll unter anderem klären
ob und in welchem Ausmaß Fahrlässigkeit
vorgelegen hat der Bund muss den
vorgesehenen Betreiberfirmen 243
Millionen Euro Schadensersatz zahlen das
hatte ein Schiedsverfahren ergeben die
PKW-Maut war ein Prestigeprojekt der CSU
der Europäische Gerichtshof hatte sie
2019 gestoppt doch bereits vor dem
Urteil hatte scheuer Verträge mit dem
Betreiberfirmen geschlossen
die Zahl der Sozialwohnungen in
Deutschland ist im vergangenen Jahr
erneut gesunken das geht aus einer
Antwort der Bundesregierung auf eine
Anfrage der Linken Fraktion hervor Ende
2022 gab es bundesweit rund eine
Millionen 88.000 Sozialwohnungen und
damit 14.000 weniger als im Vorjahr
eigentlich war die ampelregierung mit
dem Ziel angetreten jedes Jahr 100.000
neue Sozialwohnungen zu bauen im
vergangenen Jahr waren es allerdings nur
knapp
22.600 und zugleich verloren zahlreiche
Wohnungen ihre Preisbindung
bei der europawahlversammlung der AFD am
Wochenende sind nach Einschätzung des
Verfassungsschutzes teilweise
rechtsextremistische
Verschwörungstheorien verbreitet worden
Präsident Heiden waren erklärte
gegenüber der dpa die Versammlung sei
ein weiterer Beleg für starke
verfassungsfeindliche Strömungen
innerhalb der Partei deren Einfluss
weiter zunehmen bei der Aufstellung der
ersten Kandidaten für die Europawahl
habe das gemäßigtere Lager so gut wie
keine Rolle gespielt die AFD wird vom
Verfassungsschutz als
rechtsextremistischer Verdachtsfall
beobachtet
russland hat erneut Städte im Süden und
Osten der Ukraine angegriffen in herson
starben mindestens vier Menschen durch
russischen Artilleriebeschuss auch in
privi der Heimatstadt von Präsident
selensky schlugen zwei russische Raketen
in ein Wohnhaus und ein Gebäude der
Universität ein mindestens sechs
Menschen sein dabei getötet worden 75
weitere wurden verletzt
nach der Militärputsch im Niger haben
die EU und die Bundesregierung ihre
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit mit dem
westafrikanischen Land ausgesetzt sie
stellen sich damit hinter die
afrikanische Staatengemeinschaft ecovas
die bereits Sanktionen gegen den Niger
verhängt hat der abgesetzte
Premierminister des Landes machen man du
warnte im französischen Fernsehen vor
den Folgen der Sanktionen für die
Bevölkerung der Niger zählt zu den
ärmsten Ländern der Welt und vier
Millionen Einwohner sind laut UN-Angaben
auf Hilfe angewiesen
die Landkreise in Baden-Württemberg
fordern für Flüchtlinge eine Pflicht zu
arbeiten im Zweifel auch gemeinnützig
sie begründen das nicht nur mit dem
Bedarf an Arbeitskräften sondern und das
lässt aufhorchen explizit auch mit Blick
auf die Zitat dringend benötigte
gesellschaftliche Akzeptanz von
geflüchteten sprich wer arbeitet wird er
akzeptiert was aber auch Teil der
Wahrheit ist viele geflüchtete die
arbeiten wollen werden durch Bürokratie
und Vorschriften daran gehindert und
dürfen zum Teil gar nicht arbeiten weil
gesetzliche Regelungen entgegenstehen
mit denen der Staat ursprünglich
Missbrauch verhindern wollte da ist also
eine Diskussion entstanden bei der sich
manche Akteure auch an die eigene Nase
fassen müssen Eva Schiller
sie sind selbst geflüchtet und versorgen
jetzt von Tübingen aus Millionen
Flüchtlinge mit mehrsprachigen
Nachrichten ein Projekt des Landkreises
für die Redaktionsarbeit bekommt jeder
geflüchtete eine Aufwandsentschädigung
und so viel mehr findet batulhdus meine
Arbeit hat meine spracheninstrumente
einfach mal
entwickelt und hat mir die Chance
gegeben meine sprach Talente zu
entdecken sage ich mal
geflüchtete nicht nur versorgen sondern
schnell in Arbeit bringen so erklärt mir
Landrat Joachim Walter seine Vision
Baden-Württembergs Landkreise fordern
eine Arbeitspflicht für alle
geflüchteten ich glaube wir dürfen die
Menschen nicht zu fürsorgeempfängern der
gradieren den viele sind am Anfang
wirklich noch in der Lage auch was
anzupacken im Grunde genommen brauchen
wir zwei Dinge zum einen die Möglichkeit
als unsere Ausländerbehörden auch
Menschen zu verpflichten zum einen und
zum anderen auch die Möglichkeit
Leistungen zu kürzen wenn dieser
Richtung nicht nachgekommen wird eine
Arbeitspflicht beschränkt sich bislang
auf Tätigkeiten in
flüchtlingsunterkünften aber statt
Unkraut zu zupfen findet Walter sollen
geflüchtete lieber den
Arbeitskräftemangel lindern nur wer soll
das organisieren wir fragen einen der
beide Seiten kennt Rian al schebel hat
weltweit Schlagzeilen gemacht weil er
als syrischer geflüchteter zum
Bürgermeister gewählt wurde im
konservativen Ostelsheim eine
Arbeitspflicht für alle findet er
schwierig ich würde
eher mehr bei denjenigen Ansätzen die
bereits als anerkannte geflüchtete
gelten also fördern und fordern
das ist für die gesellschaftliche
Akzeptanz aber auch für die politische
Entwicklung im Land auch wichtig statt
überlastete Gemeinden jetzt noch Jobs
verteilen zu lassen fordert als scheppel
ein soziales Pflichtjahr für Flüchtlinge
mit Bleiberecht für Menschen wie Ramsi
die sich zum nichts tun verdammt fühlen
ich würde der Gesellschaft so gerne was
zurückgeben dafür dass ich hier
aufgenommen wurde ich würde auch
ehrenamtlich arbeiten ohne Geld
aber er scheitert an dem wie an den
bürokratischen Hürden das ist auch die
Erfahrung vieler Verbände gerade hängt
ein Metzger an der Strippe des
Flüchtlingsrats er möchte einen Mann aus
Gambia ausbilden aber die Behörden sagen
nein
heute stehen
ich bin dabei
und alles
für viele Asylbewerber besteht ein
Arbeitsverbot deshalb halten Sie hier
den Ruf nach einer Arbeitspflicht für
populistisch sind für mich ganz viele
Fragen offen also allein schon diese
Forderung Flüchtlinge sollen arbeiten
das ist überhaupt keine homogene Gruppe
ganz unterschiedliche rechtliche
Situationen die da reinspielen also da
müsste auf jeden Fall noch einiges
kommen um das überhaupt nur ansatzweise
umsetzbar zu machen diese Hürden das
Arbeitsverbot muss fallen fordert
Landrat Walter in Tübingen das seine
Partei die CDU diese Hürden mit
eingeführt hat um Zuwanderung zu
begrenzen ist ihm egal Deutschland muss
jetzt Umsteuern findet er
Fragen an den Landrat immer gerade eben
gesehen haben nachher im heute journal
Update und wir bleiben noch beim Thema
weil es einfach wichtig ist natürlich
für die ganz unmittelbar Betroffenen die
die Debatte über sie in Deutschland
meist erst auf Umwegen mitbekommen weil
das aber auch wichtig ist für das Klima
in dieser Gesellschaft mein Kollege Jan
Meyer hat sich die Situation in
Brandenburg angesehen wo die zuständige
fachministerin von den Grünen die
positiven Beispiele für Integration
hervorheben will während ihr eigener
cdu-koalitionspartner von schön
verreicht
Brandenburgs Integrationsministerin
trifft in der Gemeinschaftsküche auf
Flüchtlinge mit ihren Problemen
der Mann der Familienvater aus Syrien
spricht kein deutsch die Heimleiterin
springt ein Heinrich hat zwei Frauen der
ist reich ja er hat noch eine Frau mit
zwei großen Jungs sechs Personen
zu finden die Wohnungsnot hemmt die
Integration allein in diesem Jahr nahmen
Brandenburg etwa 10.000 Flüchtlinge auf
100 Leben in dieser Sammelunterkunft in
Luckau einer von ihnen Ibrahima Lee aus
dem Iran
er rappt auf Farsi und spricht englisch
der Elektrotechniker wollte längst
arbeiten doch ein Jahr lang wartete er
auf seinen Deutschkurs
jetzt werde ich erst einmal Deutsch
lernen was sehr schwierig ist danach
will ich noch eine Ausbildung machen
ihrer integrationstour durch Brandenburg
hört Ursula nonnemacher von Defiziten
bei Bildung Wohnraum und Arbeit die
Grünen Politikerin die aus Hessen stammt
wird dennoch für die Integration
möglichst jedes Flüchtlings
wir haben in Ostdeutschland gerade hier
in Brandenburg einen massiven Arbeits-
und Fachkräftemangel das wird in anderen
Teilen Deutschlands auch in den nächsten
Jahren so werden aber da wir hier eine
alte Bevölkerung haben und nach der
Wiedervereinigung auch viele Menschen
hier weggegangen sind ist es bei uns
jetzt schon besonders gravierend doch
der Integrationskurs der Landesregierung
stößt auch auf Skepsis besonders in
Cottbus in der jeder achte Bewohner
Ausländer ist die 100.000 Einwohner
Stadt ist eine Hochburg der AFD die
Leute die hier Probleme machen in der
Stadt Davos Integrationsprobleme gibt
ich glaube nicht dass die
Integrationskurse reingehen wenn man
sich die Menschen in der Stadt anschaut
dann bin ich mir ganz sicher dass sie
nicht in irgendwelche linken
integrationsvereine gehen also ich
glaube da wird sehr viel Geld ausgegeben
und der Nutzen den sich gar nicht in der
Stadt das sieht die Stadtverwaltung
anders direkt gegenüber vom Rathaus
öffnet morgen ein willkommenszentrum das
ausländischen Fachkräften Orientierung
geben will doch die eigentlichen
Probleme sind damit nicht gelöst es gibt
ein paar Sachen die wir noch verbessern
können wo wir auch noch Potenziale sehen
aber wo wir jetzt wirklich an die
Kapazitätsgrenze Tatsache räumlich und
auch Personal gestoßen sind ist
Tatsachen sozialen Bereich was Kita
Schule und die Gesundheitsversorgung
angeht
Integration gelingt nur mit Sprache
Ministerin nonnemacher finanziert
deshalb einen dolmetscherdienst den
Flüchtlinge online kostenlos nutzen
können so informierte sie auch zum
Abschluss ihrer Tour heute in Belzig
schnelle Erfolge sind gefragt denn im
nächsten Jahr finden in Brandenburg
kommunal und Landtagswahlen statt
so jetzt bei uns noch mal du Hannah ja
und zwar mit zwei Meldungen heute aus
der Eurozone zum einen ist die Inflation
im Juli weiter gesunken und liegt jetzt
bei 5,3% zum anderen ist die Wirtschaft
im zweiten Quartal stärker gewachsen als
erwartet Valerie Haller es bleiben
allerdings Sorgen Kinder darunter auch
Deutschland was sind die Gründe dafür ja
wenn man nach den Gründen sucht lohnt
der Blick in die USA dort ist die
Konjunktur auf wachstumspart was auch
daran liegt dass sie eben in Bereichen
die Zukunft versprechen die Nase vorn
haben und kräftig investieren nicht nur
die Wirtschaft selbst sondern auch die
US-Regierung ja und vor allem in die
Themen Digitalisierung und künstliche
Intelligenz ja stattdessen ist in
Deutschland viel traditionelle
industrieansässig die besonders unter
den hohen Energiepreisen echt
Unternehmen wie BASF ziehen
Produktionseinheiten schon ins Ausland
und schon macht das Wort das kranken
Mannes von Europa die Runde die
Aussichten sind tatsächlich
die Zeit eher düster laut
Internationalen Währungsfond haben sich
in allen großen Industrieländern die
Aussichten verbessert nur in Deutschland
nicht der DAX scheint sich dagegen heute
nicht zu sorgen der erreichte
zwischenzeitlich ein neues Rekordhoch
wie passt das denn zusammen das passt
insofern zusammen da die Unternehmen im
DAX sehr international aufgestellt sind
und die wirtschaftliche Lage in
Deutschland nicht allzu sehr ins Gewicht
fällt Dax-Konzerne erwirtschaften 80
Prozent ihrer Umsätze im Ausland und da
sind die konjunkturellen Aussichten
einfach besser seinen frischen Rekord
konnte der DAX zwar nicht halten am Ende
aber steht bloß ein kleines Minus damit
liegt er immerhin noch in der Nähe
seines Allzeithochs und beendet den Juli
mit rund zwei Prozent plus vielen Dank
Valerie für deine Einschätzungen
nach den Blockaden mehrerer Flughäfen
durch die letzte Generation will der
Lufthansa Konzern Schadensersatz geltend
machen im Juli waren durch Blockaden der
Aktivistinnen und Aktivisten dutzende
Flüge in Hamburg und Düsseldorf
ausgefallen zudem geht es um einen
Protest im vergangenen November in
Berlin neben der Lufthansa hat auch der
Flughafen Düsseldorf angekündigt
Ansprüche gegen die klimaaktivisten
durchsetzen zu wollen in welcher Höhe
ist noch nicht bekannt
die Unesco hat empfohlen Venedig als
gefährdetes Welterbe einzustufen
Massentourismus und der Klimawandel
hätten der italienischen Lagunen statt
zugesetzt wenn die Behörden nicht mehr
täten um Venedig zu schützen würden
irreversible Schäden drohen im September
will das Welterbekomitee über die neue
Einstufung abstimmen Venedig und seine
berühmte Lagune stehen seit 1987 auf der
Weltkulturerbeliste
bei der Fußball-WM der Frauen konnten
heute die Gastgeberinnen aus Australien
ihren Einzug ins Achtelfinale feiern sie
sieht mit 4:0 gegen Kanada die
Kanadierinnen schieden überraschend aus
ebenfalls weiter ist Nigeria nach einem
0:0 gegen Irland und Japan siegte 4:0
gegen Spanien damit sind beide
Mannschaften im Achtelfinale Sambia und
Costa Rica ist das Turnier dagegen seit
heute beendet hier der entstand drei zu
eins
in Hollywood streiken sie ja gerade weil
sie Angst haben vor künstlicher
Intelligenz die künftig ihre Jobs im
Filmgeschäft übernehmen könnte der
zunehmend schmale Grad zwischen Mensch
und KI ist auch bereits Thema im Film
selbst und zwar gleich hier im ZDF
montagskino das morgen Projekt und das
wird sicher spannend und später gibt es
dann noch unser heute journal Update
gegen 23:35 Uhr mit Christopher Wehrmann
von uns allen hier ein angenehmer
[Musik]
guten Abend der Juni war 15 Prozent
nasser als das Klimamittel der Jahre
1991 bis 2020 und 30 Prozent nasser als
das Klimamittel 1961 bis 1990
deutschlandweit kam im Schnitt 100 Liter
Regen pro Quadratmeter das was wir
gerade erleben ist typischer
mitteleuropäischer Sommer kaum ist das
eine tief nach Osten abgezogen kommt
schon das nächste gleich hinterher und
das nächste das da kommt ist das Tief
Xan und das bringt auch viel Wind mit
und eben Regen bis Mittwoch Abend können
in Süddeutschland bis zu 120 im Norden
bis zu 70 Liter pro Quadratmeter fallen
der Regen bereitet sich heute Nacht über
den Westen und den Süden Deutschlands
aus kleinere Bäche und Flüsse können
dadurch aus über die Ufer treten weniger
kräftig fällt der Regen hier im
Nordosten aus der Wind kommt aus
südwestlichen Richtung die Temperaturen
sinken auf 17 bis 13 Grad und morgen
sieht der Regen weiter nach Osten dann
lockert es vorübergehend etwas auf und
es entwickelt sich kräftige shower und
Gewitter und auch morgen über Tage weht
der Wind recht böig aus westlichen bis
südwestlichen Richtungen und die
Temperaturen steigen im Dauergrau am
Alpenrand auf 17 am Mittel unterm
Oberrhein bis auf 23 Grad und
wechselhaft geht es dann auch in den
nächsten Tagen weiter mit kräftigem Wind
hier im Südwesten am Mittwoch und die
Temperaturen liegen dabei bei 17 bis 25
Grad guten Abend